Hình phụ hoang ra các buồn chia bán anh chỉ tiền yêu cầu cơ bộ ngành và cơ quan nhẹn ước,
chìa khai các biển pháp tiếp kiện nương lợp.
Chúng bất cảnh giá như lượng tôn câu tăng cao gió tất động từ tự nhiên trung đông.
Giới chức cao buồn chia trở biết muốn cung như liệu và điện trung đương dẫn và được bảo đảm o định.
Giờ chiến đánh giá của cơ tụ quan trung năng và xuân dịch như khầu,
chính phụ ra bộ kinh tế và tải chính giá xuất chi tiêu,
ư tiên cắt giảm các khoản, liên quan đến sự dụng như liệu,
đi lại và có hỏi đồng không thiết yếu,
bộ nơi vô đường yêu cầu rung gián địa phương, tăng cường quan li giá thông,
hạn chế un tắc sâu thông nhằm dạm tiêu hông như liệu,
để cạnh đó có thơ quan được quyến khiết định mạnh họp chực tuyến,
hạn chế dùi chuyển đường dành,
bộ mò và năng lượng sẽ bán anh hình gián cuộc thề về tích kinh diện,
đồng thời phối hợp năng cao năng càng hiện thức cộng đồng.
chính phụ cám bất chiếc kêu cầu cầu tụa bộ hi đống chính quyền thực hiện nghiên cứ biển pháp,
nhìn bộ đồng hiệu quản xử dụng năng lượng, chục dụng khó khăn hiện này.